Rusia advertido de que si Ucrania
entrarse en la ota en esto provocaría
una escalada bélica que podría
desembocar en una tercera guerra mundial
así lo ha explicado el vicesecretario
del Consejo de Seguridad de Rusia
Alexander Benedicto cuando ha comentado
la propuesta ucraniana de entrar en la
otan que se formuló Poco después de que
Rusia se anexionase cuatro territorios
ucranianos el propio Benedicto dice que
está convencido de que los países
miembros de la otan en su mayoría salvo
tal vez los bálticos se dan cuenta de
que la entrada de Ucrania en la lead
atlántica sería un suicidio y que por
eso las principales potencias que
integran la alianza atlántica no
apoyaron la propuesta en su momento para
Rusia los países occidentales los países
de la otan hace tiempo que están
luchando indirectamente en esta guerra
Aunque desde las capitales europeas y
desde Washington se insiste en que no
están luchando contra Rusia